[Music]
dune is probably one of the few
hollywood productions that will probably
be released in the cinemas
this year but before we can finally
expect a trailer for dune on september
9th
we have to be content with the newly
released photos the magazine empire
offers in its september issue five scene
pictures and three potential magazine
covers of this science fiction
blockbuster
the perps most interesting cover shows
us a first look at the giant sand worms
that colonize the planet in dune
on another cover we see some members of
the house at radius more precisely the
protagonist paul atreides his mother
lady jessica
his fatherlito and the weapon master
gurney helic finally the third cover
shows stilgar his daughter johnny
and the planetologist lied kinds on the
far right you can
also see jason momoa in his role as
duncan idaho
but empire magazine reported that he's
not one of the fremen in terms of
content the new adaption of the sci-fi
novel of the same name by frank herbert
is about the complicated story of the
noble family trying to gain power
of the desert planet erik is however
after deception the plan
fails and paul etraedis has to flee as
the son of the family
into the wasteland to build up an
alliance with the nomadic tribes and
push back the galactic emperor
dune is expected to be released in
cinemas on december 18
2020. those who are already in the mood
for a little foretaste can look forward
to september 9th when the first
trailer will finally be released
this week we have some news about marvel
and dc superhero movies
first of all there is ant-man 3. in a
conversation with sirius exam director
of peyton ritz that the third ant-man
part would be much
bigger than its two predecessors of
course reading couldn't or
didn't want to go into too much detail
but he's supposed to have a completely
different template than in the first
movies
not so surprisingly since rick and morty
producer jeff loveness was hired to
write the screenplay
an exact release date for ant-man 3 has
not yet been renounced
but the film will most likely be part of
phase 5 of the mcu
more superhero news are also announced
for dc's black adam
in the past many fans have often asked
themselves in which universe the movie
belongs to
as the whole thing has become a bit
confusing since joker and the batman
producer hiram garcia gave a surprising
answer to the magazine collider
he didn't announce an exact universe but
he did reveal
that they wanted to expand the world
with black anime and the justice society
of america called
jsa garcia was much more specific about
black adam's arch enemy shazam
which is said to exist in the same world
since both logically draw their powers
from one source
black adam is supposed to be released on
december 22nd 2021
after the production was paused in march
the production of the falcon and the
winter soldier is back on track
allegedly it will start next week in
georgia so that filming can continue in
october in the beautiful czech capital
proc
it is hoped that the disney plus series
with anthony mackie is falcon and
sebastian stannis winter soldier will be
released this year as
announced last but not least there is
some news about doctor strange the
multiverse of madness
after numerous pandemic related
postponements there are now reports that
doctor strange 2 will already start
shooting in november
one reason for this could be that the
lockdown has played into the hands of
new directors sam raimi and author
michael waldron
as both were hired relatively recently
after director scott derrickson ended
his collaboration with marvel some time
ago
the expected release date of doctor
strange the multiverse of madness is
march 25th
2022. the fresh prince of bel air is
probably one of the most
cult 90s sitcoms ever after the last
official episode was released in 1996
variety reports that a small reunion of
the stars around will smith is about to
happen
just in time for the serious 30th
anniversary one of us streaming servers
hbo max is now recording a special
similar to the new edition of friends
about the content of which almost
nothing is known yet
if you believe variety at least the most
famous stars of the sitcom are returning
this special will be recorded in the u.s
on september 10th so that the episode
can be streamed in time for
thanksgiving completely unexpected 43
year old chadwick boseman died last week
of a colon cancer illness which was
unknown among fans the king t'challa
actor leaves a great legacy in hollywood
especially because of his legendary
acting skills
since even in the middle of the
treatment phase of his disease the actor
did not shy away from continuing to
stand in front of the camera
boseman celebrated his breakthrough in
his role as baseball legend jackie
robinson in the film 42
however he only achieved worldwide fame
later through the role of t'challa in
black panther and the avengers films
meanwhile marvel released a touching
commemorative video which not only
features numerous behind-the-scenes
footage but also
interviews with black panther director
ryan coogler fellow mcu members lupita
nyong'o
michael b jordan chris evans robert
downey jr and marvel boss kevin feige
in general the sad news has caused a lot
of sympathy not only in the fan
community but especially among acting
colleagues and other stars the names
range from the rock jamie foxx to
ex-president barack obama
the letter reminds us on twitter of a
meeting with boseman at the white house
when he was playing jackie robinson
terry crews hal berry oprah winfrey and
many other celebrities of the black
community also honored his life's work
major league baseball also honored the
actor by saying that by playing jackie
robinson in the movie 42
he played a timeless role that will
outlive future generations
[Music]
do